[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute einen freien
tag xxl ich wollte schon immer mal
diesen trend jetzt mitmachen mit dem
mittellinie die dann so aussieht als
würde man so ein stückchen vom kuchen
inneren sehen ich finde es eigentlich
richtig hübschen hab mir dann die ganze
bank was machst du für ein motiv in
welche richtung ich welche farbe etc
und dann habe ich mir gedacht das
besondere an meinem freund layer cake
ist dass er richtig in die höhe geht und
dann benutze ich jetzt endlich mal mein
xl tortenring den er so lange schon im
shop also seid unser shop eröffnet hat
für 600 ja im april haben wir den schon
im shop und der wird auch fleißig
gestellt und nicht bekommt noch ganz
viele anfragen wann machst du mal was
damit und heute weil vor der kamera ist
der kamera bestimmt öfter was damit
gemacht habt ihr auf instagram gesehen
oder heute mal von der kamera selbst
will ich glaube ich viel drum herum
schnacken
ich habe für meinen vorteil 16 und
bisschen was vorbereitet und damit das
video nicht so endlos lang wird und ihr
euch nicht langweilt habe ich mir
gedacht den boden also das grundrezept
für meinen boden einen extra video da
habe ich das noch mal für euch abgefilmt
da habe ich mir aus könnt ihr euch da
angucken ich habe jetzt hier den
durchmesser von 18 zentimetern genommen
ihr könnt übrigens auch in der form
direkt backen oder ihr machts wie ich
und nehmt euch drei tenöre torten ringe
und back den dann dreimal und habt ihr
nämlich drei bilden und diesen dann auch
immer gleichmäßig hoch und was wir auch
machen könnt ist die swiss mit
buttercreme und das habe ich ja auch
schon vorbereitet gibt es auch in einem
extra video kann ich aber wirklich viel
geredet im intro ist will ich auch
direkt zum nächsten step übergehen und
das ist eine frucht einlage ich will dem
tatortes ein bisschen die schwere
wegnehmen und daher machen wir nur
frucht einlagen und dafür zeige ich euch
hier die drei zutaten
wir benötigen saft eurer wahl das kann
kirschsaft im der sagt et cetera sein
dann habe ich hier noch ein paar
tiefgekühlte erdbeeren die kennt doch
anruf früchte nehmen und ganz wichtig
unser geliermittel die agah tine und das
ist ein pflanzliches schnee mit
das könnt ihr dann auch gerne verwenden
wenn jetzt zwei spiele keine gelatine
also keine schweine oder rinder gelatine
möchte jetzt gehe ich einmal über zum
topf habe so machten cut und dann geht
es weiter
[Musik]
den saft gibt ihr einfach zusammen mit
der agad ihn in einen topf gerührt das
ganze um lasst das einmal aufkochen und
dann zwei minuten lange köcheln lassen
in der zeit entwickelt sich die
lehrkraft und engagiert ab einer
temperatur von circa 35 bis 38 grad das
zeige ich euch aber gleich noch
den fertigen saft gibt ihr dann in
schüsseln und da müsst ihr wirklich auf
die größe achten ich habe jetzt die
böden eben 18 cm durchmesser gebacken
und die frucht einlage die vita daneben
spricht ein bisschen kleiner sein
müssten damit sie eben nicht aus guckt
und da habe ich jetzt schüssel mit 16 cm
durchmesser genommen habt ihr frischer
gefühlt drumherum getan damit das auch
später richtig gut rausgekommen und dann
einfach fair aufgeteilt also gleichmäßig
aufgeteilt und jetzt nehmt ihr euch noch
eure tiefgekühlten früchte können auch
gerne frische linie nach saison und
verteilt das dann auch gleichmäßig noch
mal drauf und die könnt ihr vorher auch
noch mal klein schneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt ist das ganze ja nur noch
schnell ihren das heißt es muss abkühlen
damit eskaliert und das könnte jetzt
entweder auf zimmertemperatur machen
oder zum beschleunigen in den
kühlschrank geben könnte platz hat oder
aber auch wenn ihr sagt ich möchte das
ist auf vorrat machen und immer wenn ich
mal wieder was backe habe ich nur frucht
anlage da dann könnte so auch einfach
komplett einwickelt also nachdem es dann
an geliert ist einfach nochmal
frischhaltefolie oben drüber und dann
einfrieren und dann hätte es auch
wirklich ein paar monate jetzt geht es
an die leckere füllung und dafür
benötigen wir kalte schlagsahne
hier habe ich etwas mascarpone zucker
zum süßen himbeer oder apple marmelade
könnt euch aussuchen und etwas sahne
fest dies wüssten mehring buttercreme
ist auch sehr sehr lecker die habe ich
mit richtig viel man in der extrakt
aromatisiert aber ich finde damit das
ganze so ein bisschen leichter mit den
ist schon eine torte also xxl damit es
ein bisschen leichter wird neben uns
sitzt seiner mascarpone für die inneren
schichten und dafür nämlich jetzt alle
zutaten und verriet sie in einer
küchenmaschine könnt ihr eure
handrührgerät verwenden also alles
nacheinander reingeben und solange mixen
bis es eine schöne feste masse ergibt
[Musik]
nach gut zwei minuten sieht die creme so
aus also sie es richtig schön fest
geworden und alles hat sich miteinander
verbunden und sie hat auch eine schöne
rosa farbe bekommen wegen der marmelade
das gebe ich jetzt ganz kurz an die
seite und kümmere mich um meine böden
die sind wir jetzt hier ausgekühlt also
vorgebacken und ausgekühlt und die werde
ich jetzt durchschneiden ich brauche
insgesamt sechs böden und jeder boden
ist bei mir eineinhalb zentimeter hoch
und darum kümmere ich mich jetzt
[Musik]
so hießen jetzt haben wir alle
komponenten beisammen
wir haben die böden die buttercreme
außerdem die sahne mascarpone creme und
die frucht anlage genau jetzt haben wir
alles zusammen und jetzt ist es wie so
eine art leinwand das heißt ihr könnt es
jetzt füllen und schichten und dann
einstreichen und das ist jetzt
eigentlich so der coole part finde ich
und ich mach das jetzt so ich habe immer
mein konstrukt ich habe hier eine
drehbare tortenplatte weil da kann ich
einfach viel besser mit umgehen viel
besser verstreichen und auch vor allem
gleichmäßiger verstreichen darüber gebe
ich dann jetzt schon die tortenplatte
auf der ich meine tasche servieren
möchte da muss ich das später nicht noch
mal extra umstürzen oder so was also
dann spart ihr euch diesen schritt und
das ist viel viel einfacher
ich mache das jetzt so dass ich anfange
mit dem ersten boden
ich trinke ihn noch mal zusätzlich mit
ein bisschen zucker sirup ihr könnt auch
milch nehmen und auch gar nichts ganz
wie ihr möchtet und die torte wird sehr
hoch also wenn ich hoch sagte haben sie
würde diese dann wird sie auch sehr hoch
und daher mache ich das jetzt so ich
fange jetzt an zu schichten und
irgendwann merkt ihr okay jetzt kannst
du ein bisschen wackelig werden dann
nehmt ihr euch den xxl tortenring und
spannt ihn einfach drum herum
das geniale ist der hat jetzt zwei klemm
hebel ihr kennt ja schon den tortenring
mit einem kabel patentiert von der firma
jahres mit der wir jetzt seit einiger
zeit auch zusammenarbeiten und wir haben
denen ja auch wie schon am anfang des
videos sagte von anfang an im shop und
heute kann ich euch das endlich mal so
ein bisschen demonstrieren warum zwei
klaviere fragt ihr euch
doppelt hält immer besser also müsst
euch vorstellen der held hier oben schön
fest ohne dass er verrutschen kann und
dann würde er ja unten in die breite
gehen und um das zu vermeiden hat man
hier eben noch den zweiten und da kann
auch mit der zeit nichts passieren wenn
material edelstahl wisst ihr ja kann
sich auch hin und wieder mal bei hitze
verbiegen und das passiert hier einfach
nicht und ich kann drücken wie ich will
der geht immer auch seine ursprungs
opposition zurück und daher liebe ich
den song und jetzt schnack ich nicht
viel drumherum sondern zeigt es euch
jetzt einfach mal
[Musik]
ich spritze jetzt hier noch ein
buttercreme ring bzw 2 drumherum einfach
zur stabilität das ist einfach nur damit
ihr auf der sicheren seite sein
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles was soll ich so
große historische alles was ich da hatte
einfach hier in meinem tollen ring
gepackt und der ist jetzt sage und
schreibe 20 zentimeter hoch also ein
richtiger power tower power cache und
den gebe ich jetzt in den kühlschrank
war jetzt muss ja alles so ein bisschen
fest werden die buttercreme wird sowieso
sehr fest im kühlschrank und das
brauchen wir jetzt auch also mindestens
30 minuten und dann geht es an die
decoder aufhorchen schon am meisten bis
gleich die erste kürzer ist es
überstanden und alles so schön fest
geworden jetzt entfernt ich einmal den
tortenring und dann wird die torte
einmal rundherum ganze mit buttercreme
eingestrichen also einfach nur aus dem
grund damit die krümel gebunden werden
können und wir später keine krümmel
außen haben weil das sieht einfach nicht
schön aus
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier noch einen ganz
wichtigen tipp für euch die torte ist ja
nun mal ziemlich hoch und bei hohen
torten das kennt ihr vielleicht auch von
hochzeitstorten ist die gefahr groß das
ist mal so nach links oder nach rechts
schwenk wir haben zwar eine gute feste
buttercreme aber trotzdem sicher ist
sicher daher nehme ich mir in
schaschlikspieß und gibt jetzt einfach
in die torte reihe könnte je nach höhe
der torte einfach kürzen die spieße und
dann rein legen falls solche stinkt ja
aber was wenn dann die gäste darauf
beißen das ist ganz einfach so ihm merkt
euch wie viele jeder rein getan habe zum
beispiel fünf oder sechs und bei
mannstaedt und sagte dann hat man zu da
sind jetzt 50 spitze
wenn die alle raus sind dann sind wir
alle safe und besuchen das macht also
genau das macht man halt sogar hohen
torfhaus genau ihr müsst nicht denn die
steht da vielleicht eine stunde auf dem
street table und macht ihren job sieht
gut aus und schmeckt dann im nachhinein
natürlich auch gut und das jetzt einfach
dass euch da kein desaster passiert also
mit den spitzen braucht euch keine
sorgen machen
[Musik]
die krüge schicht ist gebunden und gebt
euch da jetzt noch nicht so viel mühe
weil das sieht man sowieso nie später
das ganze wird jetzt nochmal gekühlt
mindestens eine halbe stunde bis er
merkt dass die äußere buttercreme
schicht richtig schön fest geworden ist
und dann zeige ich euch video das mit
dem fall klein macht bis gar nicht so
die buttercreme schicht ist jetzt kühl
und auch hs könnte daran erkennen dass
wir da einfach drauf anfasst und dann
nichts an den fingern kleben bleibt also
alles wunderbar und jetzt zeige ich euch
meine neuen streubel wir haben demnächst
ganz neue ihr vater sie jetzt mit diesem
video das wir streusel im shop
aufgenommen haben ich sage gerne springt
weil die sind vom happy swing kids und
die bieten jetzt auch im shop an nicht
nur die sondern auch ganz viele andere
varianten
ich habe euch einfach mal um im shop und
ich sag ich jetzt wie ihr die linie mit
den streuseln hinbekommt ihr nehmt euch
jetzt eure buttercreme die er die ganze
zeit hier auf zimmertemperatur auf euch
wartet das ist wichtig damit sie schön
weich ist und wie sie verstreichen
können die kommt jetzt in einer linie da
könnt ihr euch jetzt entscheiden möchte
ist dick oder dünn oder lieber unten
die kommen jetzt einfach auf die hart
gewordene buttercreme und da befestigen
wir dann unsere spring cals
[Musik]
sobald die sträuße schön daran haften am
besten noch mal kühlen also ihr könnt
damit nichts falsch machen denn stellt
euch mal vor ihr fand jetzt an mit der
weiteren buttercreme und dann verläuft
euch das irgendwie oder die streusel
faina passiert gerade im sommer mal
genau also ich hab jetzt auch noch mal
kühl alles ist wieder wunderbar fest
auch hier die schicht die ich jetzt noch
drauf gestrichen habe und als nächstes
einfach mal die restliche butter kleben
einfärben in ihrer wunschfarbe ich hab
jetzt rosa genommen hat wenn das jetzt
hier in meinen spritzbeutel getan
hier vorne eine blatt töne eine große
ich kann damit einfach besser arbeiten
und jetzt also dürft ihr auch gerne
wieder grob arbeiten gleich streichen
oder das ganze ja glaubt hier nochmal
der tipp von mir ganz ganz wichtig
gerade bei solchen feinarbeit nehmt euch
immer die drehbare tortenplatte und
runter und dann die buttercreme und
einfach oben und unten richtig schön
verteilen
[Musik]
also ich muss ehrlich sagen etappenweise
sieht der kuchen echt schlimm aus wenn
ihr den grob einstreichen wenn ihr dann
erstmal nur die sträuße ich hab dann
denkt man sich so was ist das denn aber
jetzt sieht man erst mal die richtige
optik und das ist richtig cool aus ich
habe es jetzt erst mal grob verstrichen
mit meiner winkel palette und der
eigentliche schritt kommt jetzt ihr
braucht jetzt eine große teil karte ihr
könnt natürlich meine nehmen wie gib zu
ihrem shop die ist besonders groß dies
22 cm groß und der kuchen ist eben 20
zentimeter hoch daher passt gerade
perfekt und wir müssen jetzt mit der
tankkarte die buttercreme glatt
streichen also nicht abziehen und
wegnehmen sondern einfach nur glatt
streichen
[Musik]
nachdem ihr dann die ränder auch noch
mal schön platt verstrichen habt habt
ihr eigentlich schon den effekt also man
sieht ihn schon ganz gut aber da fehlt
noch ein bisschen was an deko und gibt
es ganze nochmal die kühlung damit die
buttercreme wieder mal sehr schön hart
wird und ihr auf der buttercreme pinseln
könnt also ihr nehmt euch jetzt ganz
einfach goldene lebensmittelfarbe dies
flüssig und pinsel damit den rand an der
stelle wo ihm die spring bild anfangen
also ihr demonstriert den rand noch mal
so ein bisschen und das sieht auch ein
bisschen eleganter aus
[Musik]
warum meine lieben jetzt fehlt nur noch
ein bisschen deko an der oberfläche und
ihr dürft euch jetzt nicht wundern wenn
ihr merkt halt wieder tageslicht ja also
wir uns ist das ja so dadurch dass wir
die videos drehen müssen wir immer bei
tageslicht film beziehungsweise wollen
wir das denn das für euch auch
wunderschön aussieht und daher ist jetzt
der nächste tag sap dass hier noch mal
in die kühlung gegeben und ihr könnt
natürlich alles an einem tag werden was
ich gemacht habe ist einmal ein bisschen
schlagsahne aufgeschlagen also ganz
gewöhnlich auf schlag
mit ein bisschen lebensmittelfarbe
einfärben und jetzt werde ich hier noch
so ein paar hosen oder ich mach lieber
so richtig lange häubchen ich glaube das
gefällt mir besser weil der geht ja so
ein bisschen in die länge wenn ich jetzt
hier noch sechs stücke drauf spritzen
und dann noch so ein bisschen bildwinkel
dekorieren oder stift ich auch nicht
wohnen geht ich mache mich jetzt so ein
bisschen größer weil die torte ist
ziemlich hoch und so kann ich einfach
besser spritzen
[Musik]
und fertig ist der fall ein cache in xxl
und ich habe jetzt oben drüber noch
unsere xxl kugeln gegeben die haben wir
jetzt auch im shop und das ist nicht
wirklich so dass man sagt okay
typisch streusel man bei sap irgendwie
auf stahl geschmack genau darauf was
hartes sondern das ist natürlich quatsch
die kugel drin auch in den kleinen also
das ja das stimmt es gab doch mal so
eine kita variante das war dann auch so
kugeln sowie malteser auf jeden fall
sehr lecker findet jetzt auch im shop
genauso wie dem xxl tortenring und an
einen utensilien die ich jetzt hier
benutzt habt also schaut gerne mal rein
und ich wollte euch noch unbedingt den
tipp geben falls in der baby shower
party ihr macht dann macht ihn auch
gerne nach
ich will das ist eine hübsche rosa genau
ihr könnt ja natürlich jetzt auch blau
nehmen also eigentlich ist es mitunter
baby shower krieg richtig cool
also ich freu mich ich bin gespannt was
ihr zu sagen habt schreibt mir gerne
euer feedback und in die kommentare
und dann natürlich das bäumchen nicht
vergessen ein abo noch die schaute
selbstvertrauen für die tote ist das
freut mich
das freut mich als ich bin gespannt was
ihr jetzt noch sagen dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten mal auf die
diskussion jarvis
[Musik]